- Hey, welcome back, everybody.
I hope you had a
good lunch break
and got a chance to
see the poster session.
There were amazing
posters there.
We now have the first of
our two keynote speakers,
followed by a panel and
the last keynote speaker.
I want to thank Ellen
Douglas for coming in
at the last minute
and rescuing us.
We had Tony deBrum from
the Marshall Islands
who was going to talk
about sea level rise.
But we wanted to talk
about sea level rise,
as you saw the issues
in the previous panel.
And so Ellen has graciously
agreed to talk about them.
We've had the stage set
with the previous panel.
And on Monday this week, we also
had Kerry Emanuel from MIT talk
about hurricane risk
and how to evaluate
hurricane risk, which it turns
out, is not a trivial matter.
One point that he made and
which is quite interesting
is that, number one,
sea level rise is not
the same throughout the globe.
It's going to change
depending on where
you are for various factors,
not the least including
gravitational attraction.
So we know roughly how
fast it's rising here,
but we don't know if
it's going to take off.
There's a range
of climate models.
And when you start to think
about mitigation, which
is probably what we're going to
have to deal with because we've
already dumped CO2
into the atmosphere,
and we're going to
have to live with it,
and live with ocean level rise,
then the question becomes,
how do you mitigate it?
And that mitigation is going
to depend very strongly
on where you are-- what
the coastline looks like
and what the bathymetry is.
So Ellen, who's a professor
of hydrology at UMass-Boston
has studied this
extensively, and has
worked on mitigation
strategies for cities,
and is actually very
directly involved
with developing mitigation
strategies for Boston.
So we'll have a talk and have
about 15 minutes for question
and answer afterwards.
So Ellen, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Hi, everyone.
Can hear me?
Is my mic on?
Oh, great.
So yeah, thanks for
having me here-- happy
to fill in, last minute.
I love talking
about sea level rise
and how we can deal
with it in Boston.
So what I'm going
to do is give you
a whirlwind tour of some of the
projects I've been involved in,
dealing with that.
But I wanted to give you a
little bit of a precursor
to begin with.
We're used to hearing,
recently, about a lot
of different records that
are being broken, right?
We have record
temperatures every year.
temperatures in the months.
And just recently, July 2016
was deemed the hottest month
ever recorded.
So we're breaking
a lot of records.
And I always like to mention
that records are always
going to be broken.
Theoretically, they'll
always be broken.
But usually what happens is, the
time between records increases.
But what we're seeing
with climate change
is that the records
are being broken
faster and faster and faster.
And so it gives us an idea
that something's going on.
Also I don't know if you noticed
but, just a couple of weeks
ago, we had a King Tide.
And so there was a
whole bunch of pictures
that were taken of
places around Boston
and the surrounding area
where you see that there's
water just at high
tide, in places
that generally
didn't see flooding
before-- so more evidence
that things are happening
that are unprecedented.
And of course, we know this
from the International Panel
on Climate Change, when
they, in their last report,
came out and said that,
"warming is unequivocal."
And in other words,
there's no doubt anymore.
And it's extremely likely
that humans are the cause.
And so what do we
do with that, then?
Well one of the
things that Boston
did was the Green
Ribbon Commission, which
is a part of a little--
committee in Boston
decided they wanted to do
a vulnerability analysis
for the city of Boston.
But before that, they
wanted to pull together
a scientific consensus on
what climate change means
for Boston.
And so this Climate
Ready Boston initiative
was born just last
year, summer of 2015.
And the first thing we
did was bring together
four teams of scientists from
around the city to look at,
what is the latest-- what is the
most recent science on climate
change impacts for
Boston, with regard
to temperature, storms,
precipitation, and sea level
rise.
And I'm going to talk to
you about sea level rise.
So the ultimate
outcome of this project
was, they took the consensus
from the scientists,
did a vulnerability
assessment, and then next
we'll look at plans for
reducing the vulnerabilities
that they identified.
I'm going to talk
about-- so this
was called the Boston Research
Advisory Group, or BRAG.
I'm going to talk about the
results of the Sea Level Rise
Team in the BRAG.
This is a list of
the people that
were involved in that team.
Myself and my colleague
Paul Kershen at UMass-Boston
led the BRAG teams.
So I don't know how much--
this is kind of last minute,
so I don't know how
much you've already
seen about sea level rise.
But I want to talk a little
bit about the process.
There's a lot of
different factors
that go into sea level rise.
Of course, as the water
warms, it expands.
So that's called
thermal expansion.
Also, you have melting of ice,
of glaciers, and ice sheets,
adding volume to the water.
You have vertical land movement.
So sometimes, in some places,
the land is subsiding.
Some places, it's uplifting--
compaction, other things,
all these add to sea level
rise as we experience it
at any location.
Over the 20th century,
thermal expansion
was really the driving factor.
But in the 21st century,
as we move further
into the 21st
century, what really
is striking is the
potential for ice melt
and the melting of the glaciers
to really add and accelerate
the sea level rise that we see.
So in the ice sheets,
there's a potential of tens
of meters of sea level
rise, were they to all--
and now, they're not
going to all melt
in the next few centuries.
But there's a big potential.
And that's one of
the big uncertainties
in being able to project
sea level rise, especially
out into the later part of
the 21st century-- just how
much of that ice
is going to melt?
So the other thing, that
I know Kerry talked about
earlier this week, was
that sea level rise is not
experienced in the same
way in every location.
So here in Boston, we're
not going to see just
global mean sea level rise.
GMSLR is just Global Mean.
That's just the average sea
level rise around the planet.
We're going to experience a
different rate of sea level
rise because of this
vertical land movement.
Here in Boston, we're
actually subsiding.
And part of the
vertical land movement
is in response to
glaciers that were
like 12 to 20,000
years ago-- the land
is still adjusting to that.
We also have changes in
ocean dynamics, which
I'll talk about in a minute.
And we have something
that's called ice sheet
fingerprints, which
I think you've had
a little bit of exposure to.
But that is one of the
coolest things I learned
as being a part of this BRAG.
So I thought it was
very interesting
and I wanted to
share that with you.
So the ocean dynamics is-- as
you know, I'm a hydrologist.
So I deal with freshwater.
So I didn't have any real formal
training in ocean dynamics.
And I found out that
the surface of the ocean
is actually very bumpy.
Because of currents, it's
not flat like you'd think.
And so as those currents make
their way around the globe,
the different elevations
of the water surface
are very different.
And as those elevation
as those currents change,
it changes-- it affects the
elevation of the water surface.
So as warming occurs,
sometimes we're
expecting that some
of the currents
may slow down, which may
cause a relaxing of the water
surface at the current and shift
the water at the shoreline.
There's also changes due to more
or less saltiness in the ocean
and warmth.
And then we have
these big climate--
what they call teleconnections--
where these big climate
events-- one, in
particular, in the Atlantic
is called the North
Atlantic Oscillation, which
effects where currents go and
also affects the sea levels as
well.
So these ocean dynamics
could impact sea level rise
along the New England coast as
much as 10 centimeters by 2100.
So there's all these
factors besides just
the thermal expansion
that add to the sea level
rise we may see.
This idea of ice fingerprints
is pretty amazing.
So as ice sheets
melt, they add water.
That's obvious.
But one thing that
I didn't realize--
I never quite understood until
I was a part of this BRAG--
is that the ice sheets
are so massive that they
have a gravitational pull.
And they actually pull
the water up to them.
And as they melt, then
that mass reduces,
and so the gravitational
pull reduces.
So when you're close to an
ice sheet that's melting,
the water level--
even though water
is being added to the
ocean at that point,
the water levels are actually
depressing, going down.
That means it's distributing
farther out into the ocean.
So when you're far
away from an ice sheet,
the water level's actually going
up because of that ice sheet
melting.
And so they can model--
they've gotten better
at modeling and predicting
these kinds of impacts.
So this line, here,
is how the ocean
would look if it was just a
flat surface around the sphere.
But this line here
shows that impact
where the massive
ice sheet is pulling
the water up next to it.
And then as the ice sheet
melts, this water level
actually drops here and
goes up farther out.
So we're going to be--
because we're very far
from the Antarctic
ice sheets, we're
actually going to be seeing
more than global mean sea level
rise because of this relaxing
of the gravitational pull
from the ice sheets.
Which I just think that's
really fascinating.
I would have never thought that.
So because we're close to
Greenland, as Greenland melts,
we're actually going to see
a reduction in sea level rise
because we're
close to Greenland.
But Greenland is pretty small
relative to the Antarctic.
So as the Antarctic
melts, or if it collapses,
we're actually going
to see as much as 20%
or more increase over
global mean sea level rise
because of that impact of that
mass redistribution of water.
And so all those
things were taken--
the BRAG looked into all
those different factors.
And actually, Rob DeConto,
who works at UMass-Amherst,
has a method for incorporating
all that into a model that
can then project levels
of sea level rise,
specifically for Boston here.
So out of the BRAG came
some specific predictions
of sea level arise under the
different emissions scenarios.
You probably learned something
about emissions scenarios.
If we have low carbon
emissions, because we
go to renewable energy
sources, or if we continue
on with the high
burning of fossil fuels,
we have high emissions scenario.
So here is the high emissions
scenario sea level rise.
So it could be as
high-- the mean
around four to five
feet of sea level rise,
could be as high as seven
feet of sea level rise
by the end of the century.
Whereas if we follow the
lower emissions scenarios-- so
if we reduce our carbon
emissions in the atmosphere,
we could then have
sea level rise
that's more in
the realm of three
to four feet, two to four feet.
So what we do now--
what the take away
from for many of the things
that came out of the BRAG was,
what we do know makes
a big difference
later in the semester.
(LAUGHING) Semester!
You can tell-- later
in the semester
and later in the century.
Right?
[LAUGHTER]
- Quite a long semester.
- Yeah, that's a very
long semester, right.
Yeah, you probably
won't see the impact
by the end of the semester.
- The final exam--
- Yeah, the final, right.
There will be a test at
the end of this century.
How did we do?
(LAUGHING) That's good.
So that was one Initiative
that Boston generated
to try to assess what
climate change means
for Boston specifically.
And they're just
finally releasing,
I think it should come out
in the next month or so,
the results of the
vulnerability assessment
that used the
scientific consensus
from the BRAG for
the four impacts,
and then look at places in
the city that's vulnerable.
Another project that
I was involved in
was actually funded by the
Federal Highway Administration
and Mass DOT.
I'm an engineer, so I like
to deal with the stuff that's
on the ground.
So we worked, we were hired
by Mass DOT and the Federal
Highway Administration, as part
of the climate change pilot
project to look at the
impacts of sea level
rise and coastal
storms on the Central
Artery, what we affectionately
know as the Big Dig
around here.
So I'm going to tell you
just a little bit about that.
Here's our project team,
and included several people
from UMass-Boston.
Our modeler was Kirk
Bosma from Woods Hole
Group down in East Falmouth,
and Mass DOT personnel.
So we all worked
together on this.
And the main
objective was to see
what was vulnerable in
the Central Atery project.
And we're not just talking about
the tunnel but all the highway
infrastructure and the tunnels
that were a part of it.
And then how could
we-- what could we
do to reduce those
vulnerabilities?
So this is just an image
of the Central Artery.
I'm sure that you're
all pretty-- well,
maybe you're not.
You're not, maybe,
from around here.
So this is the Central Artery.
Here's a picture of what it
looks like now, where the Rose
Kennedy Greenway used to be.
It was an elevated highway.
Now it's a tunnel
under the city.
And so you can imagine that
an agency like Mass DOT
worries about things
like tunnel entrances.
What happens if water goes
in the tunnel entrance?
Or they have these
big vent buildings.
So when you've got this tunnel,
you need to ventilate it.
So they have these
big vent buildings.
And they have vents
right at ground surface.
So you have to worry
about what sea level rise
or coastal flooding could
look like in these areas.
And I've done a lot of work.
I've been working on
this for over 10 years
along with my other colleagues.
And what we had
previously done was just
what is called a bath tub mat.
So you just take a flat
surface, and you cut it
through the terrain, and
you say, anything below it's
going to be flooded and
anything above it is not.
Well that's fine when
that's, basically,
all you have the
money or time to do.
But really, what
you need to do is
develop a model that can
simulate waves, and wind,
and ocean current
so that you know.
Because this map
shows a flat surface
at 12 feet where flooding
would be in Boston.
But this actually shows
how a hyrdodynamic model
would simulate the
same kind of an event.
And so you can see the red
means higher than 12 feet.
So along-- this is actually
a simulation of a nor'easter.
One of the reasons that
nor'easters impacts us
in Boston is because
Boston Harbor is open--
opens right up to the Northeast.
So people along the South coast,
here in Quincy in those areas,
are going to get higher
impacts because of waves,
and because the water is
push-- because of storm surge--
than they are in
the Northern coast.
So that's why we decided that we
would-- because we had funding
from the Federal
Highway Administration
and from Mass DOT, we built
this big, fancy-shmancy model
that actually includes
much of the Atlantic
so we could bring in nor'easter
storms and hurricanes
to assess what those would
look-- what flooding would
look like from those events.
And we also, because Mass DOT
was interested in understanding
the vulnerability of
individual structures-- so
the vent buildings,
the tunnel entrances,
things like that-- we had a
very fine-resolution grid.
So all of these little
dots-- the model
had a prediction
for all those dots.
So this ended up being a
very large numerical model
that was built.
But it really was
the next step that we
needed to take beyond
the bathtub maps.
We incorporated sea level
rise, we picked points off
of the highest
emissions scenario
to look at what coastal
flooding would look like now,
in 2030, and 2070,
and ultimately 2100.
And the outcome
of this-- so this
was like a two year project.
And the outcome of this
model was the probability
of flooding at
different locations
throughout Massachusetts--
throughout Boston.
So it was funded by Mass DOT--
they were most interested
in the Mass DOT structures.
But it also gave
us a map where you
could-- where other people,
other communities all
along the coastline could look
at the results of this model
and say, what does that mean
for flooding for us as well?
So this is an image of, as
you can see, the Boston area.
The little-- the
green here-- so this,
right now, is the
probability of flooding.
So the greenish color
is around 1% chance.
So if any of you ever heard
the term, The 100 Year Flood
or the 1% Chance
Flood, that's the one
that FEMA worries about a lot.
So we were able to
actually predict
what the probabilities
of flooding were.
And this is the
Greenway in East Boston.
Here, we have South Boston.
Here, we have down where
I am on Columbia Point,
up here in Charlestown.
So this is current conditions.
So there is some probability
of flooding in parts of Boston
under current conditions.
But the probabilities
are low-- 1% or less.
But when we get to 2030,
you see the colors change.
Not only do the colors change,
but the extent changes.
So now the probability is
more in the area of 2% to 5%.
So now we're starting
to see, rather than once
every 100 years
on average, we're
seeing once every 50 years
or more-- probability
of flooding-- and also seeing
much greater extent of flooding
in these areas as well.
And then we get the 2070.
And then we start seeing
a lot of flooding.
And in particular, we
see a lot of flooding
in here, in Cambridge
and Back Bay
because-- so what
we're doing here
is we're modeling sea level
rise plus the addition of storms
coming in on top of that.
So a storm surge--
so by 2050 to 2060,
somewhere around
in there, if you
get an event-- a storm
surge on top of a high tide,
it can actually get
around the Charles River
dam and the Amelia Earhart dam.
And then you begin to have
flooding in these areas that
weren't used to being
flooded, because that's
why the dams were put there.
So we have flooding in
Cambridge and those areas,
a lot of flooding up in
Charleston and Somerville,
and of course, South Boston,
South End, and all these areas.
So this gave Mass DOT a chance
to figure out what is the risk.
What's the probability
of getting flooding?
And we could also take a
particular probability--
a 1% flood probability-- and
see what the depths would be.
So here, we're looking at
the same sort of scale.
The Greenway in East Boston,
under current conditions,
has a potential.
If it's a 1% event,
if that occurs,
the depths are going to
be around a half a foot--
a half a foot to a
foot-- so not anything,
probably, terribly disruptive.
But if you get into 2030,
then you get an extension,
then the flooding depths
get more extensive,
and they get deeper.
And again, as you
can imagine, by 2070,
not only do you
have a higher chance
of flooding in more areas,
but you also have more depths.
So this gave Mass
DOT-- and anybody else,
basically, in Boston that's
interested in the impacts
of coastal flooding, which is
the combination of sea level
rise and coastal storms-- some
information to how to plan,
how to think about what
sea level rise could mean.
And of course, we can zoom in.
Mass DOT and others can look
at individual infrastructures.
I showed this map to
a bunch of CEOs that
had property in South Boston.
And there was literally
a verbal gasp in the air
because the blues are around
30% to 50% probability, by 2070,
of flooding.
So that's a really
high probability
of flooding occurring
in these areas.
So then you can start
looking at what are we
going to do about it.
So other things that come out
of this model are the timing.
So the water comes in, we
know what the depths is,
how long does it last?
So how deep it gets, how
long the flooding lasts.
Then you can start
figuring out what
we're going to do about it.
So you could do something
as simple as putting up
flood-proof doors.
We found out in the Big Dig,
there are a lot of doors.
There are an enormous
amount of doors.
So as they replace
doors over time,
they replace them with
flood-proof doors.
So that's a fairly easy fix.
There's also, in areas that
are going to be flooded,
but it's going to be
either less than two feet,
or it's going to occur
over a very short time,
you could put up these
things called temporary flood
barriers.
Aquafence is a builder of
these temporary flood barriers.
And Massport actually
has bought a system
of these temporary
flood barriers.
And this shows a picture of
them doing an emergency-- see
how long it took.
And it took them like,
I think, 45 minutes
to put up the temporary
barriers around
this particular building.
So they went and did a drill.
So there are ways that
you can protect yourself
that aren't terribly
expensive and can
be put away in the warehouse.
And then when you--
the good thing is,
we have three to
five-day lead times
now, for big storms
that are coming in.
So you have time to prepare.
So this gave Mass DOT
a chance to really
know what sea level rise
and coastal flooding
would mean for their
particular infrastructure,
and then to be able to plan.
So the good news, for
them and for Boston,
is that over the short term,
currently, there is exposure.
There is risk of flooding.
And we kind of all
knew that, right?
Now we just know what
the probability is.
So it's fairly low
probability right now.
So we have time
to figure out how
we're going to deal with this.
But by the time you
get to 2030, you
have to start worrying about
more substantial flooding
and incorporating
this flood-proofing
and accommodation
into the maintenance
of these particular buildings.
The bad news is there
were some-- even
under current conditions,
there are some tunnel openings
that are vulnerable.
So you have to think
about what we would
do if a storm did come in.
And those vulnerable tunnel
openings do increase over time.
So Mass DOT is doing a lot
of ground truthing right now,
making sure that the
stuff that the model said
is actually true.
And then they're also developing
a plan over the long term
with how they're going to
incorporate this information.
Just one more quick
thing about other things
that we've been doing
related to sea level
rise in the Boston area.
My colleague, Paul
Kirshen and I have
been working for about the last
eight years in East Boston.
We had a research
project that was
funded by NOAA, the National
Oceanographic and Atmospheric
Administration who was
interested in knowing
what sea level rise
and coastal flooding
means for environmental
justice communities.
And so we picked East
Boston as a focus area.
And the first thing we did was
we had two research projects.
So this is research in action.
We had two sequential
research projects
where we went in and met
with East Boston residents,
found out what they knew
about climate change.
We gave them some ideas of what
we knew about climate change,
and then surveyed the
residents to find out--
and told them about what are
the options-- how can you
protect yourself, how can
the city protect itself
from these flooding events--
and then got feedback
from the individual residents
as to what they felt would work
and wouldn't work.
And out of that, then,
came a series of workshops
where we brought together
people from Boston agencies--
Massport, Mass
DOT, National Grid,
the City of Boston,
all kinds of agencies
that were going to be
doing individual adaptation
strategies in East Boston--
brought them together
with the residents
of East Boston,
had some workshops where
people shared their values
and their priorities.
The whole purpose was--
the hypothesis here
was that, if you develop
a plan, rather than having
all the individual
agencies develop
their own plans for
their own infrastructure,
if we got together and came
up with a plan that shared
the plan across agencies
and across stakeholders,
we could not only
meet the requirements
of the individual
agencies, but also
have a lot of co-benefits
for the residents
and other people
involved in the area.
So we brought together--
and this was mostly
led by Paul Kirshen--
the residents
with the governmental and
infrastructure agencies, shared
values and plans, and
then engineers came up
with a conceptual
flood-proofing, flood
protection plan for East Boston.
So people just got together,
rolled out these maps,
and said, OK, what's important?
People listened to
different stakeholders
giving presentations,
and sat down,
and hashed out what was
important, and ultimately came
up with a map of
important features,
within East Boston, that
needed to be protected,
that were valued by
both the residents
and the government
agencies and infrastructure
agencies that were involved.
And ultimately, out of
this came a conceptual plan
that included a flood wall, that
included some landscape berms,
and some beach nourishment,
and things like that.
And the great thing about
this is, since the NOAA--
the NOAA funded research that
we did lasted for six years.
And then Paul and
NOAH-- N-O-A-H,
which is the neighborhood of
affordable housing community
advocacy group in East Boston--
went and got a Kresge grant.
Yeah, so we were funded by NOAA
and we were working with NOAH.
It was hard-- N-O-A-A, N-O-A-H--
so, got a Kresge to actually
develop a real adaptation
plan for the city of Boston.
And then very recently, the
Coastal Zone Management--
it's hard, that's kind of washed
out-- but the Coastal Zone
Management has given
the city of Boston money
to actually start designing
protection for East Boston.
And that includes-- so one
of the things that came out
of this model-- we have--
so you saw the flood
maps from the model
that showed flooding,
and the probabilities, and the
depths at different places.
The other thing that the model
shows you is flood pathways.
So there are places
along the coast that
are an entryway, that if
you block that entryway,
you can actually save a lot
of the flooding behind it.
So what the Coastal Zone
Management-- Massachusetts
Coastal Zone Management
has actually given money--
a grant to the city of
Boston to develop designs
for closing those gaps.
So one of the gaps
was the flood pathway
that leads to all that flooding
that happens in the East Boston
Greenway.
The other is a
flood pathway that
leads to flooding that comes in
up by the Schrafft's building
up in Sullivan square.
And that leads,
ultimately, to water
that gets behind the
Charles River dam.
So you close these two
flood pathways and you
save a lot of flooding.
So you don't have to do all
of that individual home flood
proofing.
So I really like this East
Boston project because it
started by talking with the
residents, and now has ended--
is currently in design stage.
So it was really a
great example of how
you can work with a
whole bunch of people
and come out with something
that's actually going
to happen-- be on the ground.
So I'm going to end there.
My colleague, Paul
Kershen, started this work
in East Boston
with a study called
"Climate's Long-term
Impacts on Metro Boston."
And one of the take
away messages from that
was that, "The most
expensive option, when
dealing with climate
change, is to do nothing."
so that's what I wanted
to leave you with.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you very much.
So we have time for
questions allocated.
They're bringing the
mic up to the front.
So we ask that you line up,
and identify yourself, and ask
your question.
I wanted to-- I don't
know if it's out of key
to talk about another
town in the area.
But-- so every winter
, there's a nor'easter.
And we see these news
things of Scituate.
- Yes.
- And it just kind of boggles
my mind that it's there.
And I just don't know what
will become of Scituate
in the future in 2070.
- Well, Scituate's been the
focus of a lot of-- I mean,
Coastal Zone Management, they've
done a lot of monitoring there.
They're doing a lot of
site-specific evaluations
of how to protect Scituate.
Because it's just the
geometry of the embankment
there, that-- they get blasted.
They're just unlucky, I guess.
- OK, so we'll take
our first question.
- Hi, I'm Melissa
Goodman from Harvard,
and this year from Radcliffe.
And my question
is, in Chicago-- I
know that in the middle
of the 19th century,
they raised Chicago up-- all
the buildings and all the land,
about six feet because
Lake Michigan smells.
But anyway, I'm curious whether
actually raising the city
is just so expensive
or so impossible
that that's not even
part of these plans.
Or is part of that
thinking in there?
- Well we haven't gotten to--
so what most agencies in Boston
and entities in Boston
have done at this point is,
either they're in the process of
or have completed vulnerability
assessments to know exactly
what is vulnerable in the city.
And the city of
Cambridge and a lot
of communities along the coast
are doing these vulnerability
assessments, looking at
different levels of sea level
rise, and saying,
OK, what buildings
are going to get flooded,
and things like that.
Now, once those vulnerability
assessments are done
and we're getting to
the end of that phase,
that's when the hard
part comes to try
to figure out what to do.
I've heard people talking
about raising the city.
There's another
thing that people
have talked about for
the last, probably,
20 or 30 years, about putting
a barrier along the harbor
islands.
So those are the
kinds of things,
now, that we're going
to have to start
looking at the feasibility of.
There's all those ideas, but
is it really feasible to do it?
So I don't have the answer
yet, but maybe in 10 years.
- Next.
- My name is Ned Bacon.
That last comment goes
directly to my question.
I'm aware there's been
a lot of studies--
there's been a lot of
talking about the problem
here in Boston, which
is the really easy part.
- Right.
Talking is always easy, right?
- Yeah.
And at the same time, I see
this enormous amount of building
that's going on, particularly
down in the seaport district.
And I'm wondering if the people
who are doing that-- or you
see General Electric
coming in and getting
financial concessions
from the city,
as opposed to contributing
to a potential solution
to this problem.
I'm wondering if
those-- I don't know
if you're in touch with the
developers in that community,
but are they living in
a parallel universe?
- Well I can't-- I have given
these talks so many times that
I can't believe they're
living in a parallel universe.
So one of the reasons
that the Boston--
that the BRAG-- the Climate
Ready Boston Initiative
came out was to
really focus on Boston
and figure out what's
vulnerable, and how much,
and what needs to be done.
And this Mass DOT study that
I showed you was done-- funded
by Mass DOT and the Federal
Highway Administration,
but it's also available
to pretty much anybody who
wants to use that
information to figure out
what their vulnerability is.
So the information's out there.
The city is not,
to my knowledge--
now, I'm a hydrologist,
I'm not a policy person--
but to my knowledge, the city
is requiring that people who
build-- they're requiring
that they account
for climate change in some way.
But they're not
specifying how they do it.
And I know there's been a lot
of murmuring about the fact
that General Electric is
building this big building
in the middle of the seaport
where you see there's going
to be a 50% chance of flooding.
And so I've heard talk about
making the first floor 12 feet
instead of 8 feet, so that they
can actually lose the bottom 4
feet and still have an 8 foot
structure-- things like that.
So I don't believe that
people are unaware,
but it's certainly
not stopping them.
That's all I can say.
There are a lot of people
that shake their heads.
Yes?
- Hi, how are you doing?
Matt [? Mulvy. ?] I'm
a Division Commander
in the first Northern District
for the Coast Guard auxiliary.
But I wear another hat
with the Department
of Defense in the Air Force.
And I'm dealing with a lot
of potential construction
on the Atlantic coast.
And looking at the
FEMA maps, should I
add another foot or two to those
when I'm looking at base flood
elevations?
- To the FEMA maps-- well, yeah.
So FEMA is-- (LAUGHING) how
much you gonna pay me for this?
[LAUGHTER]
- Well the projects
we do, we expect
them to last 30 or 40 years.
And I don't want to go
into some building that's
got four feet of water
in it based off the maps
that we have now.
Yeah, so the FEMA maps simply
look backwards in time.
They don't incorporate
climate change at all.
So FEMA maps are developed
using the historical data.
And this is by law.
I mean, FEMA has no choice.
This is how Congress
designated that they
would develop these flood
insurance rate maps.
They look in the
history, they figure out
what's the probability
of flooding given
our historical
record-- 100 year,
500 year-- so that's the
1% chance and the point .2%
chance of flooding.
What you add to that--
that's one of the reasons
we did this big
model for Boston,
because we added sea
level rise into Boston
and allowed the model to
simulate storm surge, and wave
actions, and things like that.
Because there are a lot of
other things besides sea level
that's going to
impact the coastline.
And so what you add
to the FEMA maps,
if you're going to do that,
all depends on how vulnerable--
how much risk you can take.
So if you have a system--
if you have a building that,
if it gets flooded,
oh well, it's messy.
But you just clean it out
and you put stuff back,
then you could probably handle a
5% or a 10% chance of flooding.
But if you have something
like the Big Dig,
where people drive through it,
and you don't want to fill up,
then that has a very low risk.
I mean, you could only handle
a very low risk of flooding.
So those sea level rise
projections, remember,
that I showed you-- those
things that tailed up
depending on what the emission
scenarios looks like-- you have
to make a decision
as to how much risk
you are willing to take.
And then, based on
that, the lower the risk
you can take the higher, you
have to raise your elevation.
So I can't give a
one-line answer to that.
And I wouldn't anyway,
because I'm not getting paid.
No, I'm just kidding.
(LAUGHING) I don't know
if that answered the
questions, sorry.
- So I'm Pete Girguis
on the faculty here.
So this is all in the
context of flooding.
But I'm really thrilled
to be able to ask
a hydrologist this question.
So what are the potential
impacts on freshwater?
In other words, as we start
to see sea level rise,
are we going to have--
see impacts on freshwater,
on our water table, and do you
have a sense of how extensive
that might be?
Thank you.
- Yeah, that's a
really good question.
So I have been-- it's
interesting, I'm a hydrologist
and I got involved in sea level
rise for the last 10 years,
and I'm finally getting to the
point where I can start looking
at freshwater impacts again.
So in Boston and in
many coastal cities,
we have those that duel impact.
We have the ocean
coming in from one side
and we have rivers
with flood waters
coming in from the other side.
And we also have
storm drains, right?
Where do the storm drains end?
In the ocean, usually.
And when they were built,
it was above high tide.
Well when the high
tide rises to the point
where it plugs up the end,
then that storm water that
comes in-- usually when
we have a storm come in,
and we get a storm
surge, and so it goes
above the elevation of the
outlet of the storm drain,
and so water can't flow
out there anymore--
we also have a lot of
precipitation falling and a lot
of storm water that's trying
to get out of that drain
and can't because it's being
blocked by the storm tide.
And so what happens is
the water just backs up.
So the combination of freshwater
flooding and ocean flooding
is going to be that,
upstream, there's
going to be a lot
more flooding upstream
and upriver because the water
just can't get out the way
that it would normally.
Now in the Charles-- we
have the Charles River dam
that was actually developed,
designed with 6 massive pumps
that were designed to pump the
largest flood that was ever
recorded on the Charles.
So the Charles River
dam is actually
going to be OK for a
while, up until 2060, 2065.
It's going to be able
to maintain that level.
But the storm drains and
all the smaller rivers
are likely going to see
more flooding upstream
because of that.
- Lisa [? Tripp-- ?]
what about the airport?
I notice it's close to
what you put on your map
but doesn't involve it.
Is it somehow immune from--
- No.
No.
- -- all these floods?
- No, actually it's not.
And that's a very good question.
So the maps that I showed
you were made for Mass DOT,
so we basically
masked out anything
that was outside of
Mass DOT infrastructure.
But Massport asked that
question a long time ago,
what about the airport?
So actually, they've
used a lot of the output
from the model that
was built for Mass DOT.
And one of the things that Mass
DOT right from the beginning is
say, we're going to
make this information
available to other agencies
and other communities that
want to use it for
their own, because it's
the best available information
right now that there
is in the Boston area.
And so Massport has actually
done their own vulnerability
analysis already.
And that's why they bought
the temporary flood barriers,
because they now have a really
good idea of-- interestingly,
it's not until about 2070
that the actual airport itself
is impacted.
It's fairly high up.
It doesn't look at
when you're landing,
but it's actually fairly
high up above the high tide.
But they do have vulnerability
and they actually
have a resiliency
officer, now, who
has implemented a
lot of strategies
for dealing with that.
Because the airport is
an important recovery
and evacuation component as
well as normal transportation.
- Hi, my name is Gwill York,
and I'm asking this question
as the chair of the Museum
of Science here in Boston--
really was happy when I've seen
these maps that the museum's OK
until 2060.
So that was-- whew,
I'll be long gone.
But I wanted to ask,
because I've now
been starting to
see, a lot of maps
and thinking about where
the water's going to go.
And the green ribbon
Commission is convening.
And we convened all the
cultural institutions in Boston
at the Museum of Science
earlier this week
to talk about this because
we've got collections,
we have historic
buildings, we have
all kinds of different things.
But I asked there
and I'm going to ask
here, who's convening everyone?
Because it was just Boston.
And I live in Cambridge,
and there's Arlington,
and there's Somerville,
and there are all
these different communities.
So where's the conversation
about having us really
be coordinated?
It looks like we're,
as you said, coming up
with the end of figuring out
where the water will go if it's
just left, if we do nothing?
But who's coordinating all this
activity of and great research
and entering into action?
- That's a very good question.
You know, so,
miss, I've actually
been thinking about
this question a lot.
Because as a hydrologist, I
think about storm water a lot,
with extreme precipitation.
And every town is responsible
for their own storm water
management.
Wouldn't it make sense if all
the towns got together and came
up with a plan that worked
so that everybody could sort
of take advantage of the
information others had
that all makes logical sense?
And actually, when it
comes to the adaptation
for coastal flooding,
that's beginning to happen.
So because the flooding
is so extensive
and it gets worse
over time, people
within city of Boston and
surrounding communities
are starting to work together.
There's this-- I forget
what it's called,
but there's a group of mayors
in Boston and surrounding
communities.
It's called the Mayor's
Summit or something like that.
I should know the answer
to the name of that.
But anyway, they've
gotten together
to commit to working together
to come up with a plan.
The same thing has to happen in
other areas of climate change
impact with precipitation, and
flooding, and things like that.
I don't think it's happening
yet because one of the drivers,
here in New England,
as we are a home rule
place-- so every
town has jurisdiction
over their own things--
and people don't always
like to work with other
people because, number one,
it's kind of
overwhelming to think
about dealing with
somebody else's problem
when I can barely
deal with my own.
But I think we're going to
have no choice but to move
towards that.
But I don't think
it's happening.
It's beginning to happen, but
it's not happening as much
as it should, probably, yet.
But the more we talk
about this stuff, it will.
OK, thank Ellen again.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]